hey everybody Sean McGinnis here with a
gamespot news update today PlayStation 4
owners will be able to download the new
1.7 firmware upgrade one of the largest
updates with the new firmware is the
release of share factory a simple video
editing app that allows you to add
comments and stickers to video clip
saved on the system you can export these
videos to a USB storage stick or upload
them to social media websites streaming
quality has received a new maximum tier
called best HD which turns out to be
720p at 30 frames a second here are some
of the other cool things that will be
coming with the update screensavers
adjusting the light bar brightness
disabling hdcp starting Netflix with
voice commands and controlling the
keyboard with the touch pad Sony's also
released a Vita 3.15 update making it
easier to connect the two systems and
it's also updated the PlayStation mobile
app for more on PlayStation and the
exciting world of firmware updates make
sure to check out gamespot com